the meditation is very simple it's one
that anyone can perform what you would
want to do is set a timer for about 13
minutes I don't think it has to be
exactly 13 minutes but since that's what
they included in the study you would set
a timer for 13 minutes you would sit or
lie down close your eyes and you would
simply focus on your breathing most
people are going to benefit from only
doing that breathing through their nose
but if you have some sort of obstruction
or inability to breathe just through
your nose you could probably also do it
by breathing through your nose and mouth
or just your mouth but ideally you would
do just nasal breathing for a period of
13 minutes concentrating on that
breathing and concentrating meaning
bringing your awareness your so-called
interceptive awareness if you wanted to
get really technical about it your
interceptive awareness to a point just
about an inch inside of your forehead
now of course that might sound kind of
gory to some of you who've never
actually been inside your forehead but
just about an inch behind your forehead
is where you would want to place your
concentration while also concentrating
on your breathing need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the stories
for myself today too so today let's
learn from one of
one of my take on his top 10 was a
success
here's the thing about meditation
that all studies of meditation show
which is that unless you are a very
experienced meditator
your concentration your focus will drift
away from your breathing and away from
that location about an inch inside your
head inside your brain about just behind
your forehead
that will happen maybe every 10 seconds
every 20 seconds maybe even every five
seconds but an important part of such a
meditation practice to improve
concentration and focus is that you are
continually refocusing
back to that specific location and
refocusing back on your breath
this is something that again is not
often discussed people think that if you
do a meditation and you're supposed to
concentrate on your breath that if your
mind drifts that somehow you failed in
that meditation but actually that's not
the case a huge component of improving
your ability to focus and concentrate by
way of neuroplasticity rewiring of the
circuits for focus and concentration is
the repeated return to a state of focus
from a state of non-focus or diminished
Focus okay so think about it like trying
to drive down the freeway and staying
between the lane lines excuse me and
every once in a while because there's a
bit of drift on the vehicle maybe the
wheels aren't aligned correctly or
there's something else wrong with the
chassis or the steering device it starts
to drift right a little bit then you hit
the rumble strip and then you pull back
to the center that's really what a
focused meditation practice is about as
opposed to expecting yourself to stay
between the mental Lane lines so to
speak so if you're somebody who's going
to do a practice of the sort that I
described you know 13 min meditation
practice every day you'd want to sit or
lie down close your eyes start to
concentrate on your breath Focus your
attention on a location about an inch
behind your forehead and then fully
expect that at some point you'll be
thinking about something else and that's
a cue to focus back to that location
just about an inch behind your forehead
and back to your breath
by doing that repeatedly over and over
what you're really training up is the
network within your brain that indeed
includes that prefrontal cortex that
you're focusing on as well as some other
structures the infra-temporal cortex
indeed the hippocampus a structure
associated with memory and other
components of the neural circuit that
are involved in directing our mental
focus and concentration again I can't
emphasize the importance of this
practice being one of focusing and
refocusing in fact I would prefer to
call such a practice a refocus Focus
meditation or a constantly refocusing or
maybe you all can come up with a better
name for it I'm certainly not that good
at naming things but this sort of
meditation practice has been shown in
the study the Suzuki lab and other
studies
to really improve people's ability to
focus and remain focused so much so that
in the beautiful book Altered States
they describe a number of different
meditation practices some a little bit
longer than the one that I described one
that's 17 minutes another one that's 30
minutes some people meditate as long as
60 minutes a day although that's quite a
long time in my opinion the point here
isn't how long you focus or somehow
trying to achieve Total Focus for the
entire 13 minute or 17 minute or 60
Minute bout of meditation while that
would be wonderful and I think many
people aspire to do that that's a lot of
hard mental work I think for most people
out there including myself a relatively
short meditation practice of about 13
minutes in which you fully expect your
focus and concentration to drift but
that you are continually refocusing is
going to be the most effective yes
indeed the most effective at teaching
yourself to focus and stay concentrated
in fact I invite you to interpret every
time time that you focus off that
location about one inch behind your
forehead as an opportunity to refocus
and think about the refocusing as the
trigger for teaching your neural
circuits how to focus for extended
periods of time rule number two aim for
lifelong learning on a trial by trial
basis we know that when you fail
at an attempt on the next attempt your
forebrain is in a position to to engage
better and this makes total sense right
you feel that frustration you want to
get the next one right well you're
harboring or I should say funneling more
neural resources your focus that
aperture tightens now you have to be
mindful of that too because when you
have a failure and then you're like
you're going to hit the Bulls I'm
thinking about a dartboard because I'm
terrible at darts you know sober I'm
terrible at darts
I don't even drink so that next trial
part of the problem is is that Focus can
narrow so much that you can start to
lose access to information that might
help you if you were just to relax a
little bit and dilate that focus a
little bit but in General on a trial by
trial basis focus is the cue that your
nervous system is going to be positioned
to learn better on the next trial now in
terms of Life Experiences
gosh I wish for everyone fewer failures
and more successes but you know failures
keep you humble and I've had a lot of
them I mean if people ever wanted and
they you know I'd be happy to tell you
about I mean I've made a ton of mistakes
in life a ton of mistakes some of those
were mistakes of persistence like dumb
decisions I could like it's going to
change it's going to change and it's
clearly never going to change
and then some were failures of
misjudgment about other people or
situations and a lot of them were just
plain failures like the experiment
didn't work or
the thing it just wasn't the right thing
and you try and reframe those I do think
that we owe it to ourselves and to the
people that we know to try and generate
some wins here and there and try and
help other people generate wins
um you know in running a lab over the
years and I still do
you realize that you want your students
to publish a paper and feel that success
pretty early so that they can experience
a how much work it is so they pick
problems wisely but B so they can feel
that like I can do this and I think that
um you know this gets into the
psychological as well I think that yes
failures help but success is help and
there I think
you know I function best in a team and I
think that for those of you that are
feel like you're fighting some challenge
alone I do think that there are great
resources to be had in trying to access
other you know other people as sources
of support I I think that that's a great
tool there's this whole literature
scientific literature around social
connection and how that can help us
reframe motivation and goals anyway
maybe that's a topic to expand on
another time but uh failure is important
on a trial trial by basis
people who don't experience enough wins
for a long period of time the brain is a
prediction machine after all and they
start to predict failure so it takes a
bit more work to
wedge oneself out of that rule number
three get morning sunlight I would
absolutely anchor my physiology with
morning sunlight viewing I can't help it
do you know what's interesting I'll tell
you very briefly you know what's special
about morning sunlight this low end
solar angle sunlight I don't think I've
talked about this much on social media
or on the podcast there's a group at the
University of Washington a couple Jay
and Maureen Knights they run a lab
together that sounds like a horrible
thing but they do it and they get along
very well and they've discovered
that the cells in your eye the neurons
that set your circadian clock make you
alert during the day and make you sleepy
at night and so on
those cells respond best
to yellow blue contrast and orange tones
now this is important because when you
go out in the morning even if it's not
at Sunrise but it's close to Sunrise or
you look at the sun in the evening what
you'll see is yellow blue contrast or
orange yellow blue orange that old thing
from kindergarten or first grade
that's not the color of light that
you're going to see when the sun is
overhead now this also is really
interesting because
artificial lights at least to my
understanding even the daylight
simulators have not picked up on this
it's just about bright light
someone ought to design something that
can mimic this but nature has done this
beautifully for us and so viewing low
solar angle sunlight in the morning and
in the evening is most effective because
of those yellow blue contrasts now
here's the really wild thing
those circuits that set your levels of
alertness and sleep yes they respond
best to yellow blue contrast but what
that tells us is crazy what that means
is that color vision
was probably not related to color
perception first because all of that is
completely subconscious the pathways
that do this are present in people who
are pattern Vision blind
so what do I mean I mean that color
vision likely evolved from a need to
synchronize your internal state with the
external world and the best stimulus in
the outside world to do that is yellow
blue contrast in other words our ability
to detect color was first and foremost
and we understand this based on
evolutionary genomics and so forth
to extract time of day information not
color of fruit or color of skin or
anything like that that's all secondary
which is wild and crazy and this is yet
another example of the way we think
things work is not the way they work
it's completely 180 degrees opposite I'm
just going to be a little teaser I had a
guest on the podcast he hasn't we
haven't aired the episode yet his name
is Eric Jarvis he works on speech and
language he also was admitted into Alvin
Ailey Dance Company again who are these
people he's a professor at the
Rockefeller anyway
I learned from Eric and you'll learn
when that episode comes out that you
only find elaborate speech and language
in species that also engage in dance and
song and the genomics point to the fact
that song and singing came first and
language came second
and that led me during that episode of
the podcast I wrote down in my notes I
was listening to him talk and I wrote
down in my notebook it's just scrawled
in big letters it says I am so happy
right now
I was just blown away I couldn't and it
makes so much sense when you hear it
that this colors in the sky were what we
our system is trying to extract not a
perception of those colors in the sky
because they're informing us about time
and orienting Us in time that song and
the communication of emotional states
would be simpler and more foundational
than communication about specific
patterns of language
when you hear it suddenly it makes sense
but of course we're human beings and
unless you're Eric Jarvis or Ali Crum or
Anna Lemke you think about all this
stuff backwards rule number four try
intermittent fasting I happen to be an
omnivore my goal is always to eat high
quality minimally or non-processed foods
and to eat things in moderation so I do
eat some meat from sustainable sources
or from organic sources I eat some
starches and I eat vegetables and I eat
fruits I try not to eat sugars and I
don't really like highly processed foods
at this point in my life that's me
that's what I do but I'm certainly not
dictating what people should eat I know
certain people are ketogenic and I can
say that for people who achieve ketosis
and can get into ketosis yes indeed
there is a mental state associated with
ketosis that will allow your brain to
function and to think really clearly
that many people find very attractive
and keep them going back over and over
again to a ketogenic diet I'm somebody
who for instance has not been in ketosis
many times in my life at least not
deliberately so but I actually will
ingest liquid ketones from time to time
because as of the further cognitive
enhancement and physical enhancement
that I experience on top of nutrition
that does include some carbohydrates so
there are a lot of different ways to
approach all this whether or not you're
a vegan omnivore vegetarian carnivore
Etc the point is this
your ability to focus and in fact your
ability of neurons to encode specific
information in your environment that is
to represent what's out there in the
world is actually related to your blood
glucose level now here I'm setting aside
the discussion of ketosis and and
ketogenic diets for the moment but
there's a beautiful study that was
published in neuron not long ago that
showed that the tuning that is the
Precision with which neurons in the
brain represent things in our
environment is actually much greater
when there is sufficient glucose in the
brain translate into English this means
that when we are fasted or when our
blood glucose is very low we aren't able
to perceive and think about things as
clearly now there's a Twist to this
however many people who practice
intermittent fasting and I should say I
practice a sort of pseudo-interm fasting
I generally eat my meals between the
hours of 11 A.M and 8 PM although
sometimes there's some wiggle around
that occasionally I have an early
breakfast I'm not super rigid about it
but I know there are a number of people
who are doing longer fast or they're
eating in a six hour window we did a 10
our episode about fasting you can again
find that hubermanlab.com will likely
have Sachin Panda who's an expert in
intermittent fasting on the podcast
intermittent fasting has a lot of
different potential benefits
for some people it's a convenient way to
restrict their calories for other people
it's a convenient way to avoid eating
that is it's easier to not eat than to
eat a small portion so they opt for
intermittent fasting and so on and so
forth but one of the things that you
hear very often is that some people like
being fasted because they like the
clarity of mind that it provides here's
the situation neurons unless you're in a
ketogenic diet really thrive on glucose
they love glucose and as I mentioned
before your ability to think and
perceive things is actually enhanced by
having sufficient glucose in your
bloodstream so why would it be that some
people experience a heightened state of
mental Clarity when they are fasted I've
certainly experienced that before well I
should say that provided you're well
hydrated enough and you have enough
electrolytes in your system what tends
to happen is that when you ingest food
there's a shift in your nervous system
towards so-called parasympathetic mode
that is the more relaxed you probably
heard it as rest and digest although it
does other things a more relaxed mode
that can indeed make us very sleepy if
we have too many carbohydrates that
actually can make us quite sleepy
however if we have any food if we have
enough of it that is if our gut is full
it diverts blood to our gut and we
become sleepy and we can't focus as well
so a lot of people really like fasting
in the state of being fasted for focus
and concentration because they don't
have as much of that parasympathetic
activation they're just not as sleepy
and in fact under those conditions half
as much caffeine will give you just as
much lift as twice as much caffeine will
give you on a full belly of pasta and
that's just the way that caffeine
interacts with blood glucose so what I'd
like you to imagine is if you had a
measure of focus from zero to ten these
are arbitrary units 10 being maximally
focused and zero being not focused at
all imagine a U-shaped function right
where if you're very fasted you're going
to have a high degree of focus and
concentration but then if you ingest
some food and your belly is full your
focusing concentration is reduced but
having enough blood glucose and maybe
even elevated blood glucose will
increase cognitive function so there are
two ends of the spectrum on one end of
the spectrum blood glucose is relatively
low and you're fasted and you can think
and behave in a very concentrated way
and on the other end of the spectrum you
have a lot of blood glucose or I should
say sufficient blood glucose you never
want your blood glucose to be too high
and that allows your neurons to encode
and perceive and basically allow you to
think really clearly so you sort of have
to pick your condition what do you want
for your bowel to focus and
concentration I actually do both so what
I do is as I mentioned before I eat my
meals sometime around 11AM my first meal
typically unless I'm very hungry when I
wake up and so I will do my workout and
one bout of focused work I always think
of this as my hard work early in the day
and I do that fasted I'll be consuming
water with electrolytes maybe element or
other electrolytes Maybe
some caffeine as well in the form of
yerba mate or coffee that's my first
Focus bout of 90 minutes or less that is
essentially done fasted and then I'll
eat and then I do notice after I eat I
actually have a diminished capacity to
focus but then again in the afternoon I
will do another 90 minute bout of focus
and I'll talk about some of the tools I
use to make sure that that bout of focus
is optimal for getting the most amount
of focused work done whether or not it's
mental work or physical work although I
tend to do my physical work early in the
day and my mental work both early and
late in the day so to make this very
simple or as simple as I can for you
being fasted
is great for focus and concentration
provided you're not thinking about food
the entire time and being fed is
terrific for focus and concentration
actually can improve neuronal function
provided that you didn't eat too much
food so one way to manage this is if
you're going to have a lunch to make
sure that you don't stuff yourself at
lunch that you're not overeating and to
not get quite so full that you put sheer
nervous system into this parasympathetic
mode and make it hard to focus in the
afternoon I know a lot of people
experience a dip or even a crash in
energy in the afternoon that make it
really hard to focus for that reason
I'll just remind people of a tool I've
talked about many times before which is
based on the biology of adenosine and
caffeine Etc which is to delay your
first caffeine intake to 90 to 120
minutes after waking up I know that can
be painful for certain people I violate
that rule when I'm working out very
early in the morning I'll drink my
caffeine before my workout which often
occurs within you know 30 to 60 Minutes
of waking but in general unless I'm
working out very early I will ingest my
caffeine 90 to 100 120 minutes after I
wake up so again I want to emphasize
that if you hear somebody out there say
being fasted is optimal for focus and
concentration well that is true in one
context and perhaps ideal for a certain
part of the day and other people will
say no you know neurons run on glucose
you need glucose in your bloodstream in
order to get those neurons to be tuned
that is to respond with electrical
activity in the optimal way when you're
reading something or when you're trying
to perform exercise well that's also
true and of course you can incorporate
both I in fact as I just described
incorporate both fasted States and fed
States in order to optimize my
concentration and focus also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give give you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet design specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number five
reset your energy levels
non-destructive ways to reset your
dopamine and your energy levels and do
those at least every three days
so for me it was kind of a a tough thing
to take a long walk or to spend I used
to work really hard on Mondays really
hard on Tuesdays and I would not go in
until the afternoon on Wednesdays and
sometimes not at all
and then I go in Thursday Friday and
work really really hard and then not at
all on Saturday and then maybe do a
little bit of work from home on Sunday
and I was very productive that way that
those breaks are absolutely key and it's
not encouraged so much in academic or
Tech
or maybe anything now I hear about so
much stress and overwork I say you just
do it and Define the culture and let the
results and your focus be the the thing
that defines you not how many hours
you're in there but I realize there's a
huge cognitive load in energetic load
and for that I do think these non-sleep
deep breast Protocols are where it comes
in really handy they're at least two
faculty I know at Stanford one who's a
so-called Howard Hughes investigator
who's big is those are big deal
appointments they get tons of money etc
etc and they do amazing science most of
the time
um these individuals certainly do and
they take two 20-minute naps per day in
their office when this guy came and
visited me years ago when I was at a
different University he took the time
that we were supposed to meet in my
office and talk about data he asked if
you could take a nap
and he gave a great talk that afternoon
so
there you go I do think you have to take
control of your schedule and do those
things I hope that helps and then of
course for some people exercise and so
on is the way they reset rule number six
acknowledge your fears I do cry but
again about the things I mentioned
before I realized something by the way
we just recorded an episode on Grief it
hasn't come out yet a fascinating topic
I realized at one point by the way I'll
just give this away that
um I thought I was really sad about
losing them I thought I would tear up
really easily because I was sad about
them but then I realized this gosh I
can't believe I'm gonna do this but I
realized that feeling that I was feeling
is the exact same feeling of love that I
had when they were alive so grief is
love and when you look at the literature
it's it's basically that but your brain
is freaking out because that map of
knowing where people are in space and
time grief is basically a remapping of
the space where are they time when are
they and then this kind of abstract map
represents Asian that we call closeness
and grief is this process of like
ripping ourselves off of that so in any
event what do I fear talking about
things like this
um what do I fear
um
quite honestly the my biggest fear the
thing that would just make me feel just
horrible is I I fear letting down my
friends I have an amazing I love my
family and they're wonderful but I have
this in incredible relationship to
friendship and um I just I adore my
friends and I would sooner give up all
my limbs and die before I would I would
deliberately let them down so there you
go that's what I fear most rule number
seven learn to spike adrenaline this is
a wild literature and I love it and it's
changing the way that I do things I
thought that to remember things you're
supposed to get really really excited
really focused
and remember them and guess what that's
not how you do it
there's there are data
and there are stories going back to
Medieval Times
that they used to teach kids things and
then throw them in the river
there's a beautiful annual review of
Neuroscience written by the late James
mcgaugh brilliant researcher who taught
me that in this review
and it turns out that if you want to
remember something you want to spike
adrenaline after you acquired that
information after
that means the Double Espresso and the
ice bath after you study for math
immediately after and you think about
this you know that makes perfect sense
right think about the one trial learning
that nobody wants to experience which is
a car accident or some traumatic thing
you didn't get the spike of adrenaline
first you got the spike of adrenaline
after
so
again you know I discourage the use of
excessive stimulants or you know
anything like that but if you're going
to try and remember information you need
to get your brain and body into a high
autonomic arousal State literally you
need to deploy adrenaline into your
system after you have made the attempt
to learn some information
so much so that if you give people a
beta blocker
after learning emotional information
they don't learn it as well incredible
just incredible data in animals and
humans this is the beautiful work of
Larry Cahill at UC Irvine and James
McGaw so that's how I would focus on
remembering things better and it's also
true that if you tell yourself that
something's really important to you
you'll you'll be able to learn it better
if you meet people and they tell you
their name and you forget two seconds
later well you should probably be
thinking and now I do this I meet people
and I think okay what what terrible
thing did this person do just try and
Spike my adrenaline or something like
that it's a terrible trick but I haven't
figured out a better way but that's
actually one that data supported way to
do that
easily a dozen or more studies in humans
on that very topic rule number eight
tame social media use you hear all the
terrible ways in which it's changing our
brains and I think that
again we go back to this thing is is it
the aperture that we're looking at so is
it the format that we're engaging in
things
or is it
the content well the way I like to think
about the phone is the way that we've
been engaging with the phone and the
laptop for that matter in staring into
the small visual aperture each day is
sort of like walking like this all day
long
right we have this amazing ability to
shuffle our feet and take small steps or
to take big strides to run to move I
think that's the sagittal plane for
movement I know it for the brain but it
always messes the pts are vicious people
online by the way the pts and nutrition
people I've learned to just not
not say anything about that I'm not a PT
and I'm not a physical therapist and
they do incredible work but they're like
it's a very spirited crowd
and the nutrition thing is really weird
how there I mean it's just incredible
you're either people are either throwing
liver at you or they're throwing celery
at you or they're they're fasting or
they're not fasting it's nuts
in any case
they
they social media and staring at a small
visual aperture is changing our brains
here's one way I know in which is
changing our brains and then I'll tell
you how to fix it
if you stare or look at something to
within two feet of you for a certain
number of hours each day your eyeball
actually gets longer
and the visual image then is focused in
front of your neural retina not onto
your neural retina and you are becoming
myopic nearsighted
and if you look at things in the
distance enough guess what your eyeball
changes shape and your lens will focus
appropriately the image onto your retina
take some work kids that look at things
up close too much and adults that look
at things up close so much become
nearsighted
and there's a beautiful set of clinical
trials now where mainly in kids if kids
get outside for two hours a day getting
a lot of this UVB and blue light that
we're told is so terrible for us but
they get it from sunlight
they actually can reverse myopia or
reduce the incidence of myopia maybe
even glaucoma although that's a big
Maybe
so
how much staring into a small visual
aperture is too much
I don't know but what we do know is that
we are literally becoming myopic in
terms of our vision and we're becoming
myopic in terms of our cognition and
then there's the whole business of
what's actually contained in those
tweets and those social media feeds and
those news stories which frankly I feel
like you lose either way whether or not
you're in one political camp or another
political Camp you're upset about half
of the information out there
so I feel like it's you know I and I'm
not a
I'm not someone who knows how to talk
about politics without stumbling
I didn't do well in social studies
um and this sort of thing it just never
made sense to me it just felt like the
the prize goes to the person who can
shout the loudest and the most
coherently for a moment so but I
encourage of course people to be
politically active
and I vote but but the the content is
tricky to navigate and I can't really
speak to that except that it seems to be
bothering everybody
on one side or the other or in the
middle and
the format is something that we really
understand and again I don't know of
many people that are talking about this
narrow visual window format thing it
came up more during the lockdowns when
we were all inside a lot and not looking
out at a distance the the data say to
really to try and get at least 10
minutes of long distance viewing so
longer than 10 feet away from us for
every 30 minutes of close-up viewing and
not a lot of us are doing that if you're
walking to your car looking at your
phone you're definitely losing an
opportunity
rule number nine moderate caffeine
intake I know many people are curious as
to whether or not caffeine can improve
focus and concentration and indeed it
can there is an immense amount of data
supporting the idea that caffeine
provided it's consumed in the
appropriate dosages can improve mental
Performance and Physical performance and
it largely does that through
improvements in focus and concentration
the dosage of caffeine of course is
going to depend on how caffeine adapted
you are how much caffeine tolerance you
have and that is going to vary
tremendously
depending on whether or not you ingest
that caffeine with or without food as I
mentioned earlier but there is a kind of
General range in which we can talk about
caffeine as being useful for focus and
concentration and the range is basically
from 100 milligrams to 400 milligrams I
want to caution everybody out there if
you're somebody who suffers from anxiety
or panic attacks and you're not used to
ingesting caffeine and you run out and
ingest 400 milligrams of caffeine in the
form of espresso or yerba mate or an
energy drink or in pill form that is
going to be very uncomfortable for you
you're going to be sweating profusely
your heart rate is going to increase
you're going to be quite panicked in
fact or at least anxious so be cautious
with your use and adopting of caffeine
if you're not already caffeine adapted
but most people do quite well to ingest
100 to 200 milligrams of caffeine prior
to doing some focused work and again I
recommend delaying your caffeine intake
to 90 to 120 minutes after waking unless
you are using that caffeine to really
jolt your system uh before a workout
caffeine can of course be ingested in
various forms even pill form but most
people ingest it in the form of coffee
or my particular favorite way to ingest
caffeine is yerba mate it is important
and I should note that you should
actively avoid the smoked versions of
yerba mate as they contain a lot of
carcinogenic cancer-promoting compounds
there's some great yerba mate Brands out
there that most cost effective way to
consume it would be to use the loose
leaf tea and to to pour water over that
there's one particular brand that I like
I don't have any affiliation to them
whatsoever but I've been using it for
years as Anna Park it's an organic brand
that is sold I buy mine on Amazon but
you can find it elsewhere on the
internet as well again I don't have any
affiliation to them it's just very cost
effective very clean it doesn't have the
smoked flavor at least the one that I
buy is not the smoked varieties and none
of the carcinogenic compounds are in
there at least that I'm aware of and I
like the way it tastes and it provides a
very even lift and and stimulant of that
I think certainly works for me in that a
number of people I know that have
suggested to also enjoy
yerba mate or caffeine also have other
additional benefits in particular the
caffeine in yerba mate and coffee and
other sources of caffeine are known to
increase the density and efficacy that
is the number and the function of
dopamine receptors and this has been
shown in humans several times so by
ingesting caffeine pretty regularly
you're actually increasing the ability
of dopamine to have this effect of
increasing motivation and drive I tend
to ingest caffeine only early in the day
I tend to cut off my caffeine intake
somewhere around 1 or 2 pm to ensure
that I can get into a good night's sleep
but I realize that there are people out
there that ingest caffeine as late as
two or three in the afternoon and can
still sleep fine I will caution those of
you that think that you can drink
caffeine in the evening or nighttime and
still fall asleep all of the research
points to the fact that the architecture
of your sleep and the depth of your
sleep is disrupted even if you're able
to fall and stay asleep the sleep you're
getting is simply not as good as the
sleep you would get if you were to shut
off your caffeine intake at least eight
hours before bedtime and ideally more
like 10 or even 12 hours before bedtime
but of course there are practical
constraints as well okay so caffeine is
increasing dopamine's function by
changing the number and efficacy of
dopamine receptors but of course it also
increases our wakefulness our alertness
and that is largely through the
neurochemical systems related to
adenosine which is a molecule that
builds up in our brain and body the
longer we are awake it's part of the
sleepiness system if you will makes us
feel fatigued or tired and
caffeine also operates on the
epinephrine the adrenaline system in
fact if we ingest too much caffeine
we'll sometimes get the Jitters those
Jitters are really the sympathetic as
it's called nervous systems bias toward
movement and our pupils will dilate they
actually get broader now somewhat
paradoxically when our pupils get bigger
the peoples of our eyes that is
our visual World actually narrows it
becomes more tunnel like a lot of people
don't realize this when our pupils are
really small that means we are relaxed
so if you ever see someone with really
tinies or you know pin sized pupils
they're very relaxed if their pupils are
very big they're very dilated well then
they are very amped up they're V they
are very very alert
caffeine increases alertness by
increasing epinephrine adrenaline
release both in the brain and within the
body and so that's another way that it
facilitates focus and concentration and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is control
alcohol consumption I acknowledge that
I've mainly talked to you about the
negative effects of alcohol
I want to acknowledge that many people
enjoy alcohol in moderation or even
light drinking the occasional drink or
the occasional two drinks or maybe even
on average one drink per night so seven
drinks per week I'm certainly not here
to tell you what to do and what not to
do
I do find it immensely interesting
however that first of all alcohol is a
known toxin to the cells of the body
some of you might immediately say well
wait what about hormesis what about this
phenomenon where if we regularly ingest
a toxin it makes us stronger in other
words what doesn't kill us makes us
stronger yeah there's you know some
reason to believe that might be
beneficial in terms of
some forms of seller resilience maybe
maybe no sorry it doesn't work that way
there are processes of hormesis in which
for instance exposing yourself safely to
increases in Adrenaline through you know
ice baths or other things that increase
adrenaline can raise your so-called
stress threshold but here we're talking
about cellular stress and damage to
cells
so my read of the literature and again
this is my read and I invite others to
you know provide studies or I would
prefer actually collections of studies
that point in the direction if they
exist that
alcohol can be beneficial but my read of
the literature or I should say my
understanding of what I would call the
center of mass of the literature on
alcohol
is that
no consumption zero consumption
consumption of zero ounces of alcohol
is going to be better for your health
than low to moderate consumption of
alcohol
and that low to moderate consumption of
alcohol is going to be better for you of
course than moderately High to high
alcohol consumption on the order of 12
to 24 or more drinks per week I realized
that for most people listening to this
it's probably low to moderate alcohol
consumption that is part of their
standard repertoire and
I'm not here to give you justification
for doing that nor am I going to tell
you not to do that I would like you to
consider perhaps however the negative
effects that we understand and that are
documented for instance the negative
effects of alcohol in the gut microbiome
and the things that you can do to better
support your gut microbiome the negative
effects on the stress system that HPA
axis that we talked about earlier and
the fact that even low to moderate
levels of alcohol consumption can
increase our levels of stress when we're
not drinking
and to think about
acquiring some tools and you know
getting some proficiency with tools
Behavioral or otherwise that can help
you with stress modulation that don't
involve alcohol consumption so again the
point here is to illustrate where the
problems lie with alcohol consumption
but also what I've tried to do is to
point you to some resources that can
help offset some of those negative
effects will they offset all the effects
I can't say that for sure but certainly
taking measures
to offset some of the negative effects
of any alcohol consumption that you
might
be having or doing is going to be
beneficial to you
people form these associations whether
or not through experience or through
indirect experience observing others I
think public speaking is one of the
greatest fear of dying you know I'd say
I don't it's not funny but figure of
speech I never think about dying and
being afraid of dying I think about all
the scary things that could happen while
I'm living but there are many people who
are just intrinsically afraid of dying
and so that's that's a big one
um for people that uh don't swim fear of
drowning for people that swim less so
um for people that have some sort of
psychiatric disorder genuine psychiatric
disorder like obsessive compulsive
disorder which is not just pers
obsessive-compulsive personality but
obsessive-compulsive disorder fear of
the of being discovered and the shame
that they have around their obsessions
and compulsions these are true OCD is
very common do they all live in the same
place
all of these different fears that all
exist together so I was rattling off and
I didn't answer your question
um to the the more important point so
forgive me
the short answer is they have a final
common pathway which is increased
autonomic arousal and that is funneled
through a couple what we call limbic
structures among others so there's
certainly involvement of the of the now
famous amygdala
this which means almond is his almond
shaped structure on the two sides of the
brain there's also area of the brain
called the Streator terminal analysis
also involved in fear and then the
hypothalamus this small collection of
neurons just above the roof of your
mouth which is really to me one of the
more fascinating areas of the brain
Harbors neurons that create a body-wide
and brayden-wide response to something
that the higher order areas of the brain
like the forebrain
see and perceive as dangerous as
threatening so the short answer is yes
it all funnels through hypothalamus
amygdala Austria terminalis and
autonomic nervous system that's the
final common pathway but in terms of the
variety of different things that can
stimulate fear and the ways that they
can do that that is highly contextual so
the forebrain this real estate in the
brain right behind behind the forehead
is incredible because it's sort of free
real estate for you to customize for
your life according to what happens to
you early on so for instance you might
not be at all afraid of heights
and you say well why is that so well
maybe when you were a kid you were one
of those Maniacs that like you know
doing within the states we called them
Cherry drops the kids that could you
know swing on their feet and then jump
off the the bar and then other kids are
timidly crawling to the top of the thing
don't even want to go up the ladder to
the slide there's a ton of variation and
that variation does not exist in the
kind of deeper circuitry the final
common path circuitry it exists in the
learning that we experienced early in
life one bad fall can do it I mean I Was
Bitten very badly by a German Shepherd
when I was a kid who had almost got my
eye but you know for whatever reason
I've always liked dogs anyway but there
are other things that I've experienced
that have left long-term negative
imprints so I it's highly contextual and
a lot of it has to do with what happens
immediately after the bad experience
this is why nowadays there's a lot of
legal use of the drug ketamine after
traumas you know this is all very dark
stuff unfortunately but if you you know
you just imagine the family member that
was just in a car crash and saw their
the driver their loved one impaled onto
the steering column I mean what could be
more horrible than that nowadays if they
come into the emergency room they will
often give them an injection of ketamine
which is the dissociative anesthetic to
get them to dissociate from this extreme
emotional state
so there are ways now to treat this and
ketamine is used clinically at later
periods too and nowadays there's a ton
of interest in social media and in video
games and it there have been some
measurements of the amount of dopamine
released video games especially video
games that have a very high update speed
where there's novel territory all the
time novelty is a big stimulus of
dopamine those can release dopamine
somewhere between nicotine and cocaine
so very high levels of dopamine release
social media is an interesting one
because the amount of dopamine that's
released in response to logging onto
social media initially could be quite
high but it seems like likely that
there's a taper in the amount of
dopamine but and yet people still get
addicted so why why is it that we can
get addicted to things that fail to get
to elicit the same massive amount of
pleasure that they initially did
being addicted to something isn't just
about the fact that it feels so good
that you want to do it over and over
again and that's because of this
pleasure pain balance that underlies
motivation so let's look a little bit
closer at the pleasure pain balance
because therein lies the tools for you
to be able to control motivation toward
healthy things and avoid motivated
behaviors towards things that are
destructive for you there are a lot of
reasons why people try novel behaviors
whether or not those are drugs or
whether or not those are Adventure
thrill seeking things or they seek out
new partners or you know they take a new
class as you'll notice I'm not placing
any judgment or value on these different
behaviors although I think it's fair to
point out that for most people
addictive drugs like cocaine and
amphetamine are very destructive
actually we know that about 15 to 20
percent of people have a genetic bias
towards addiction that you know you
sometimes hear that the first time that
you use a drug you can become addicted
to it that's actually not been shown to
be true for most things in most people
but for some people that actually is
true and we'll talk a little bit later
about why certain people are heavily
biased toward becoming addicts on the
first use of a particular drug it's
actually very interesting it has
everything to do with whether or not
they were formally addicted to something
else
but in any case the way that addiction
works and the way that motivation Works
generally in the non-addictive setting
is that when you anticipate something a
little bit of dopamine is released and
then when you reach that thing you
engage in that thing
the amount of dopamine goes up even
further but as you repeatedly pursue a
behavior and you repeatedly engage with
a particular thing let's say you love
running or you love chocolate as you eat
a piece of chocolate believe it or not
it tastes good and then there's a shift
away from activation of dopamine and
there are other chemicals that are
released that trigger a low-level sense
of pain now you might not feel as
physical pain but the craving that you
feel is both one part dopamine and one
part the mirror image of dopamine which
is the pain or the craving for yet
another piece of chocolate and this is a
very important and subtle feature of the
dopamine system that's not often
discussed people always talk about just
as pleasure you love social media so it
gives you dopamine and so you engage in
that you like chocolate it releases
dopamines you do that but for every bit
of dopamine that's released there's
another circuit in the brain that
creates you can think of it as kind of
like a downward deflection in pleasure
so you engage in something you really
want and there's an increase in pleasure
and then there's a without you doing
anything there's a mirror image of that
which is a downward deflection and
pleasure which we're calling pain so for
every bit of pleasure there is a mirror
image experience of pain and they
overlap in time very closely so it's
sometimes hard to sense this but try it
the next time you eat something really
delicious you'll take a bite it tastes
delicious and part of the experience is
to want more of that thing this is true
for any pleasureful experience
now the Diabolical part about dopamine
is that because it didn't evolve in
order to get you to indulge in more and
more and more of something what happens
is that initially you experience an
increase in pleasure and you also
experience this increase in pain shortly
after or woven in with the pleasure
that makes you want more of that thing
but with each subsequent time that you
encounter that thing that you pursue the
chocolate that you uh you pursue the
lover each time the experience of
dopamine release and pleasure is
diminished a little bit
and the Diabolical thing is that the
pain response is increased a little bit
and this is best observed in the context
of drug-seeking behavior the first time
someone decides to take cocaine or
amphetamine
they may do it out of boredom they may
do it out of peer pressure they may do
it to relieve some internal sense maybe
they're bored or they're just excited
maybe they're high in novel novelty
seeking there are a lot of reasons why
people might try a drug far too many for
us to you know to get into or parse here
maybe they don't even want to do it but
someone encourages them they will
experience a huge dopamine release and
they will feel likely very good
however the next time they take it it
won't feel quite as good and it won't
feel even as good the third time or the
next time but
the amount of pain the amount of craving
that they experience for the drug will
increase over time so much of our
pursuit of pleasure is simply to reduce
the pain of craving so the next time you
experience something you really like I
don't want to take you out of that
experience but it's really important
that you notice this that if there's
something you really enjoy part of that
enjoyment is about the anticipation and
wanting of more of that thing
and that's the pain system in action
learning to cultivate a a life of focus
and I should say it should be produ the
way to support that is to have
components of your day of wordlessness
and defocus I do want to emphasize that
because it's not about waking up and
from morning till till night being Ultra
focused right I don't I don't I don't do
the make my bed first thing I admit it I
sometimes like it happens midday okay
all right I wouldn't make it in the
military but we knew that already anyway
so the you know that it's about being
in in recognition of where you're at and
focused and dropping in deeply for
certain portions of the day but I also
have a deliberate decompress time of my
day right I take 30 minutes a day and I
either take a nap or I do a Yoga Nidra
or I just let my mind go but that does
mean not mindless scrolling although I
do some mindless scrolling too I allow
myself that but
having periods of the day where you let
the mind defocus and just kind of drift
in the same way that your mind drifts a
bit during sleep that is what allows you
to focus so it very intensely afterward
or on a consistent basis so it's not
about being a total animal from morning
till night and then just expecting a
switch you know switch off the the
thinking and go right to sleep it's
about for me they're really two blocks
two 90-minute blocks one early in the
day and one later in the day where I
commit to doing really focused work
twice a day and I have to fight tooth
and nail to create the space for those
and to make sure it happens and if it
and I fail a lot you know if something
gets in the way and I don't do that I um
I just try and get back on track as
quickly as possible I don't bring my
phone I put my phone on airplane mode
when I'm training and doing any kind of
physical work now because it's just too
distracting people that are always in
anticipation and desire and seeking
that's wonderful for pursuing goals
however it's terrible for enjoying life
and actually those people are actually
quite difficult to be around there's a
certain almost um sociopathic element to
people who are what they call
hyperdopaminergic people who are always
on the dopaminergic scale to the point
where they are always pursuing goals in
fact those people are known to be at
least in the psychological spectrum they
can be very manipulative you know
dopamine and the pursuit of something
doesn't necessarily have to be high
energy and intense from the outside when
you observe it from the outside in fact
there are people who will manipulate in
order to get what they want this has
been shown who have high levels of
dopamine release in their brain but
they've learned that a kind of passive
manipulation is the best way to maneuver
through a particular environment I don't
want to focus too much on sociopathy
because those are kind of extreme
examples
but it just goes to show that people who
identify a goal and realize the series
of steps that they need to take in order
to achieve that goal can either do it
through ethical means or non-ethical
means they can do it through active
Pursuit being the kind of type a person
that's always declaring their goals and
going after it posting it on Instagram
telling everybody about it trying to
recruit others there's that phenotype
there's that kind of signature of
dopamine and then there are the people
that want to get what they want and
they're doing it by always serving other
people by always taking care of
everybody else's needs by always trying
to accomplish their goals but through a
mode that at least from the outside
seems more passive or more about
supporting others neither of these are
good or bad and that's because dopamine
is a molecule it doesn't care how you
reach your goals it only cares that you
reach your goals because the internal
sensation is one again of mild pleasure
a little bit of pain although more pain
over time if you're not reaching those
goals and it takes you away from the
here and now I've all heard the sayings
you know how do you you know Journey Of
A Thousand Miles starts with a single
step or how do you eat an elephant one
bite at a time or you know they're all
these sayings and and it goes back to
the Bible and earlier right I mean this
is not new these are not new sayings but
they're showing up in different forms
what's lost in those short descriptions
however is that every step is not
equivalent if it were just at a journey
of a Thousand Miles starts with a single
step everyone would pursue their goals
everyone would push back against
adversity everyone I mean you can read
the inspirational stories as many times
as one needs and I do think
inspirational stories are a very high
value in fact I think they're vicarious
dopamine I think they give us the sense
that we could which then Orient hope
which then orients us to the world to
start yeah I'm saying maybe it's
possible for me that's right so let's
say um let's take the example of
somebody who's
um because there's a thing is that's
that story of it's not about just taking
a single step and one step at a time
is it because there's adversities every
10 steps you go and so it's harder and
harder so it's not just well it's just
very non-linear you know it's it's some
days ago you know I know this from a
scientific career it's you know some
days it's easy some day is hard it's all
over the place right so I think the
thing to remember is that dopamine is
this incredibly powerful molecule that
allows us to buffer the effort process
it allows us to be an effort longer and
it allows us to actually eventually
enjoy the process of effort and not
think about the reward but just say oh
I'm enjoying the process right well you
just described the first step the first
step in learning to attach dopamine to
the effort process which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming and
depressing and I'm not good enough
that's right I should just give up what
am I doing this for that's right it's
thoughts will affect us and they're very
realistic right I mean as Carol will say
and other people have said in the
psychology field you know positive
self-talk oftentimes unless you do it
correctly you're badly wrong you know
lying to yourself won't work saying
saying I'm I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm
a winner or you haven't won yet is is
great but that's not the most effective
use of these systems well you're also
being out of Integrity with yourself
you're you're telling yourself a lie
right you're like and then you're losing
your ability to have confidence because
you you just lined yourself right and if
it's really extreme there's a name for
it it's called delusional right right
and people will start to point that out
and then it becomes harder to recruit
people into your your goals so I think
the key thing is to attach that sense of
reward to the effort process it's saying
look
I am oriented in the right direction and
rewarding the things you're not doing
I'm not back on my heels I'm not just
staying you know I'm better anymore yeah
a good example of this came to me
recently I have a good friend he did
nine years in the SEAL Teams his name is
Pat dossett and and we were talking
about you know the Admiral mccraven
thing you know get up and make your bed
and you know and they they really do
that and I think the way it was
described was
um you know so at the end of the day
even if everything doesn't go well your
bed is still made for me that's not that
big of a reward frankly right but I and
so I said that and I I love it though I
make my bad oh I definitely made my bed
in the morning but I mean going back and
seeing that at the end of a hard day
it's not enough I felt like there was
something else there so I asked him he
said well it's very interesting because
part of it is about not just making your
bed but it's the things you're not doing
by making your bed you're not lying in
bed and ruminating you're not back on
your heels you're on your phone that's
right yeah when so when you look at and
you have spent a lot of time with people
in high performing communities
mainly through some Consulting work but
what you find is that you know we can
all be either be back on our heels
flat-footed or forward Center or mass
and when you look at people who are in
these high performance communities they
try and keep their Center of mass
forward
almost through what seemed like trivial
things like making your bed or making
the cup of coffee but it's not just
about what you're doing it's all the
things you're not doing interesting that
can put you down the path of ruminating
or put you down the path of
um unhealthy Behavior so the key to this
is if we want to be very concrete we
should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas you
know people's circumstance is different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay great but to sustain that
behavior or even to make the the
behavior pleasureful and to give you
energy the key is to subjectively reward
those steps so it's not going to be
let's say I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with the single is made up
of you know single steps but the key is
to reward the harder steps not the
easier ones and not the ones where you
get the thing that you want don't reward
yourself for putting your shoes on and
taking a step outside you could if that
was a huge barrier for you it was very
hard it is very hard for you running the
10 miles that's hard find the wall
and push a little bit further through
that wall and reward that process so
this is why I think reps in the gym the
final reps like reps to failure
are usually not the best example first
of all most people aren't doing reps to
failure and it doesn't translate to
young kids and stuff where they probably
shouldn't be doing heavy reps to failure
this kind of thing what you want however
is if you're going to go there to think
about these are the this is the hard
part because that's when adrenaline
norepinephrine are getting maxed out and
that's when you have an opportunity to
bring dopamine in and teach those neural
Pathways to slam that back down and
I don't want to um highlight them too
much because they are a very Niche and
specialized Community but you look at
people in Special Operations you look at
the
um process like the whole evaluation
process of who gets in and who doesn't
it's really about putting people into
stress and seeing who can not just make
it through that stress but buffer that
stress reward the process through
teamwork reward the process of stress
through some internal dialogue that has
everything to do with not being back on
your heels not being flat footed but
Center or mass forward and I should also
be clear I'm not talking about everybody
being super aggro and always like you
know work work yeah in fact if you're
spending too much epinephrine if you're
too much of an adrenaline junkie you
will burn out eventually unless you can
find ways to recover yourself or to
buffer that with dopamine and the
recovery process is especially important
there's a second reward system so you've
got the dopamine system and I guess to
really put a box around it the
subjective reward needs to be done at
the hardest portion of a process the
tough conversation with a significant
other it's like when it's really tough
and you want you just that's when you
want to start telling yourself this is
the this is the good part because I'm
not speaking or this is the car because
I think right I'm not reacting or this
is the good part because I'd probably
not doing it correctly but I'm on the
right path right
um they're upset they're not feeling
your empathy you know this kind of thing
or you're not really understanding
what's going on you're getting
frustrated but if you tell yourself this
is this is the neural pathway getting
ground in there like it really dialed in
so that the the next time this I'm going
to Breeze right past this that's really
how the process works because dope
remember no one comes along and drips
dopamine in your ear even if you get a
billion dollars or you win a Nobel Prize
or you win the presidency it's all
internal these neurochemicals are all
internal and while some of them are
designed to be released in response to
things very reflexively like um you know
food sex sleep you know all these things
will trigger these neurochemicals we
have this big forebrain which allows us
to place subjective context exploring in
humans is the extent to which people who
can take on adaptive decisions can take
that adaptive behaviors can take that
stress response and kind of move the
Horizon in closer and just focus on okay
I'm in the high stress regime this is
really painful we see this in we work on
people generalized anxiety who are
trying to overcome fear of heights and
just walking across a virtual height
plank can be terrifying for them but if
they can get one step in front of the
other despite high levels of anxiety
they can eventually overcome that and so
we've been looking at everything from
how breathing affects the anxiety
response to heart rate pupil size Etc
I'd be happy to talk about all that in
as much detail as you like but I think
the principle to take away is this that
the growth mindset is not about
suppressing anxiety so that you're able
to move cruise through things with ease
that's just one part of it it's really
about trying to understand that stress
response as key to your growth it's
absolutely key and I think people that
you know lift weights or run long
distance or are involved in competitive
Sports they fundamentally understand
this but even they kind of migrate away
from it over time where we recovery is
super important but you need the
stimulus right and the stimulus for
growth is that stress response and if
you think about it
evolutionarily let's say we were all
living in a little Clan here in the
audit offices and we didn't know
anything about the outside world we
would start to kind of eventually what
drove people to leave was they didn't
have enough of what they needed there's
this sort of the seeking right so if you
had enough everything you had enough
mates enough food enough water be fine
but at some point there was some
deprivation and so we had to do a risk
benefit analysis and so it was really
about taking that anxiety and venturing
out into the unknown to find resources
some people died and some people
succeeded and they were rewarded and
with that reward came the idea that ah
there's something about looking out into
the environment that's useful that can
allow me to have more than I have in the
moment but you can't divorce yourself
from the anxiety of wondering whether or
not things are going to turn out okay
you can't divorce yourself from the
anxiety of of strain and effort there's
just simply no way and in fact you
weren't really designed to do it so to
kind of peel this around to a practical
answer because I often listeners and you
know and people want to know what do I
do with this is you know I think
the field of wellness and biohacking and
high performance is great but it lacks
definition so one thing I'd really like
to see more of in the in these
communities and in the scientific
Community for that matter is more
careful definition like what is
mindfulness like really what are we
really talking about what is stress and
what are stress mitigation processes
that are useful so one thing I think is
really useful is think about real-time
tools versus offline tools I believe
personally that everybody whether not
their MMA fighter they're in a CrossFit
they're running Ultras or they're a
student in class that doesn't do
anything physical whatever it is has
four tools one tool to get you to
mitigate your stress response in real
time so let's say the stress response
hits you need to keep it you can't let
it go too high or too low you know you
don't want to suppress it but something
to do that you also probably want an
offline tool that allows you to raise
your ceiling on what stress feels like
you know I'm buds with whim and I've
known him for a long time and like you
know I think Wim Hof breathing is in
particular is a use useful tool for kind
of Shifting your perception of what
stressful is that's an offline tool it's
not you can do it in real time but it's
not you're not going to start Wim
hoffing in the middle of your like
rolling Jiu Jitsu because your breathing
has got to be devoted to other things so
you need offline tools and real-time
tools to cope with stress and I think
people need real-time tools and offline
tools to bring themselves into
heightened states of arousal right so
there are times when there's when you're
actually too low on the arousal plane
and the key is to get higher up there
where you can access even better levels
of performance and so I think the the
so-called autonomic nervous system it's
absolutely under our control it's a
total misnomer it's just that your heart
rate and your breathing are taken care
of on their own you don't need to flip
the on switch you wake up every morning
and you know if everything's going well
you're breathing and your heart rate is
going the way it should but you
absolutely have levers that you can
control and move in order to shift those
and I think that
um there's been a lot of focus on like
okay breathing is a great tool or you
know the ice bath is a great tool but we
really aren't thinking about what
they're best for and as a result of that
I don't think they'll ever evolve past
where they are unless we start thinking
okay like what's the utility of breath
holds no one can tell me like so my lab
is very interested in like in trying to
figure out what the utility of breath
holds is is it better at letting you
deal with adrenaline in your system is
it better at get carbon dioxide
tolerance you know
um for all the the incredible tools that
are out there there isn't a lot of good
information about systematic ways to
approach it and I don't want to peel
everything down to like a really
reductionist approach you know I'm
friends with Brian McKenzie and those
guys and you know Brian's about as
reductionist as you get in the
breathwork community and I love how
quantif you know how he loves to
quantify everything it's one of the
things that initially brought us
together
um as friends and as uh as you know sort
of informal collaborators but I think
that this world of biohacking needs
definition you know it's it's kind of
ironic that in the weightlifting
Community they've really really works
things down to a kind of a fine science
whereas in the endurance Community it's
kind of like
whoever you're listening to seems to be
the person who knows the most and I
don't claim to know everything or the
most at all I just would like to see
sharper definition on all this stuff
about stress stress mitigation ice baths
breathing and so on the discovery of
growth mindset is worth thinking about
so Carol's Discovery was these kids that
for whatever reason you know like doing
math problems even though they knew they
couldn't get the answers right these
were sure fail problems so it's the same
kind of people that like doing puzzles
and these kids not surprisingly go on to
do phenomenally well in a number of
different areas of academic Pursuit you
know but what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain so the action or the pursuit
of a goal not just achieving a goal and
when we step back and we look at what
that really entails at a neurochemical
level we have reward systems in the
brain they generally fall into two
categories there are the reward systems
that make you feel really good with kind
of here and now and everything that's it
within the confines of your skin and the
things you already have you know love of
your dog love of your spouse gratitude
for all the things you happen to have
and and those are generally governed by
the release of molecules like serotonin
and oxytocin okay but then there's
another reward system which is the one
that drove a lot of human evolution
which is the dopamine reward system now
dopamine is a very misunderstood
molecule it's often talked about only in
the context of reward like I'm going to
work to this goal I'm going to build my
company I'm going to you know get 10
years of press whatever it is and you
reach it and you get this dopamine
reward and indeed that's true but what's
often not discussed is that dopamine is
secreted enroute to rewards while you
pursue rewards now the ability to tap
into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute Game Changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this coveted you know pandemic
situation the but the amazing thing is
remember the brain only does five things
and we get to decide which of those
Sensations and perceptions have
relevance and which ones don't or which
ones are attached to a goal and which
ones aren't so growth mindset in its
purest form is the attachment of these
reward systems to the effort process to
the friction process and not just to
obtaining a reward and just as a kind of
final point to that there's a very um
well-known body of literature and
Neuroscience at least among
neuroscientists that talks about
something called reward prediction error
and it says if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too where you're in
real anticipation of something this is
gonna be great this is gonna be great
this is gonna be great and then you
reach that goal and it's kind of
underwhelming and that generally
triggers this this circuit that I refer
to earlier this kind of disappointment
or pro-depressive circuit so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself I'm on the right track
this friction I'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good I'm gonna tell myself this is
for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we were talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in an effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in Pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team has depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine in fact there's a much better
way to maintain ongoing action toward a
goal that also involves visualization
but it turns out it's not about
visualizing success it's about
visualizing failure the balcattis lab
and other labs have looked at whether or
not people make progress toward goals of
different types whether or not they're
thinking about the goal they're thinking
about that goal line and what they want
to achieve that long-term goal and all
the wonderful things associated with it
or whether or not they're thinking about
all the ways in which they could fail
and root to that goal right this is not
typically what we are encouraged to do
typically we are told don't imagine
failure push failure out of your mind
only focus on success you know fake it
till you make it or it's a phrase that I
absolutely hate uh frankly because it's
not even clear what that means and it's
not even clear what the ethical form of
that is I think it means continue
despite any anxiety or fear that things
won't work out but if you look at the
literature the scientific literature
what the balcattus lab and other labs
have shown is that there's a near
doubling near doubling in the
probability of reaching one's goal if
you focus routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action B
and instead therefore you take action C
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though I realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just Fitness
fitness goals and physical goals are a
very concrete thing that we can all get
on the same page about
because they're related to actions let's
say somebody that sets a goal of running
five miles four times a week minimum and
as many as seven four times a minimum
before eight a.m okay in a previous
podcast on habits I talked about the
benefits of non-necessarily setting
specific times that one will do things
but setting time blocks that one will do
things you say before 8 AM you're gonna
run five miles and that's gonna happen
up to seven days a week okay
one version of this would be okay sit
back in a chair and think about how
great you're gonna feel and look if
you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything's going to be your blood
markers of lipids Etc are going to
improve okay fine that's the
visualization goal of visualizing the
end point turns out that is far less
effective and maybe even
counterproductive compared to thinking
about what's going to happen if you
don't do this the negative Health
outcomes that are going to occur the
disappointment you're going to have in
yourself the fact that you're going to
wait until 7 30 that's not long enough
for many people to run 5 miles you go to
put it on your shoes it could be pouring
rain or even hailing or snowing outside
and now you're not going outside unless
you're somebody who's particularly
motivated to do that okay so
foreshadowing failure turns out to be
the best way to motivate toward goal
pursuit in fact as I mentioned before
there's a near doubling in the
likelihood that people will reach goals
of any kind when they're constantly
thinking about how bad it's going to be
if they fail if we think back to the
neural circuit associated with assessing
value in our goal Pursuits this makes
perfect sense the amygdala that center
of the brain that's involved in anxiety
and fear and worry well the amygdala is
one of the four core components of our
goal setting and goal Pursuit circuitry
and there's no bypassing that there is
no one listening to this or watching
this whose amygdala is not involved in
their goal setting and goal Pursuit
behavior and so while I'd love to be
able to tell you that all you should
think about is rainbows and puppies and
all the wonderful rewarding things that
are going to happen when you achieve
your goals
the truth is you should be thinking
mainly about how bad it's really going
to get if you don't do it how
disappointing yourself you're going to
feel how
it will negatively impact you if not in
the immediate term in the long term if
indeed your goal is to reach your goal
so I want to emphasize that I'm not
interested in encouraging people to
flagellate themselves I'm encouraging
people to
achieve their goals and it turns out the
best way to do that is by foreshadowing
failure and the more specific you can
get by writing down or thinking about or
talking about how bad it will be if you
don't achieve your goals the more likely
you are to achieve those goals I really
believe that we all have some superpower
that reflects maybe this is a bit of a
scientific explanation that reflects the
fact that our biology
is tilted in some Direction people often
thinks about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or I'm not a good
athlete or um whatever but
it's also tilted in the direction of
something really special so like when I
was a kid
of that age I was fascinated by animals
I was just like my and so
had I learned to listen to that more I
used to hide my interest in animals
because I thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like I didn't play the
guitar in college I didn't surf I always
like like I can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know but I
think that kind of leaning that kind of
tilt towards like huh like that's me
like you resonate with something and I'm
not the first to say this I think Robert
Greene also said this like there's a
adults will often remember back to a
time where they interacted with
something sometimes it's an object or
sometimes it's an experience and it just
felt so good like it kind of Drew you in
I would tell your young listeners to and
viewers to really
pay attention to that it can seem almost
trivial like it's rarely about the thing
you're looking at or the thing you're
doing but sometimes it's the sensation
of running sometimes it's it's the
sensation of viewing seeing something or
hearing something because there's a hint
there and it's that it's not really
about what you're looking at or you're
doing it's that feeling like learn it
that feeling is your compass like that's
your true north because that's the
feeling you want to get to for to find
you know the mate for your life the you
know the partner for your life the the
career track and over time you're gonna
pivot right I mean you're not gonna get
it on the first try I eventually my
story of science started there it told
me right there I I felt it in that
conversation with my dad and then my
compass was all over the place and
spinning and eventually it's it's come
back I found it but getting it get in
touch with that feeling and if this
seems at all abstract I would do it as
an experiment
I would sit in a chair and I would think
about something you don't like
me like really don't like and I would
pay attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body I'm not a
very somatic person I'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body I've always felt like my emotions
were my head so when people talk like
their emotions and their other places
I'm just like I'm like I don't get it
but I would encourage them to think
about that and then I would encourage
them to think about something they
really like
that could be roller coasters could be
music could be get specific and to get
in touch with that feeling and that
feeling is your guide that feeling is
your compass because the nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will Orient toward the things that it's
best equipped to do
it really will
and I really animals do this naturally
my Bulldog Costello never tries to be a
different kind of dog he never fetched
once first time I threw the ball he
walked to the ball he sat down with the
ball he destroyed the ball because
that's what Bulldogs do
you know throw it to a retriever they
bring it back because the brain of the
retriever is wired to feel good by
retrieving and the brain of the Bulldog
is good to feel good by being horizontal
with and pulling on things with their
they like to tug so I think humans we're
so we're similar enough but we're
different in the sense that you have
something installed in you that feels
right and getting in touch with that
feeling is key and you're not and I
should tell that there's no you're not
going to get it right away this is a
practice you learn like shooting
basketballs or or math you do it over
and over so that but if you get started
young at eight or nine oh my goodness
great and if you do it when you're 12 or
even if you're 60 and you do this you'll
find that pretty soon you start steering
in these directions and I I do believe
it's a nervous I think our it's a neural
there's a real physical substrate for
this it's not mysticism and whether or
not that competition is with you know
um mental material like books and
studying or whether or not it's physical
competition we need external influences
like I think we these days we're so
attracted to the idea that we can you
know control everything from the inside
but you need Humanity interaction it's
absolutely necessary and I think that
um you know it sort of Harkens back to
the story at the beginning it's like all
the the stress and that I was going
through in those years I mean it
absolutely made me better right
absolutely maybe I wouldn't trade it for
anything I don't wish hardship on people
but humans are remarkable in their
ability to step into Challenge and to
meet challenge you know I think that
there's this important and very very
serious conversation now about mental
health right the number of people
suffering is just tremendous but I think
that we also are forgetting that you
know that suffering process is is it's a
jumping off point right and I've had a
number of friends commit suicide I
understand just how you know that's
that's a horrible tragedy and depression
is absolutely terrible but there's also
this question of you know sort of like
what is our expectation about our mood
right like we're so what do we really
what are we really trying to achieve
with our moods and so I always say you
know there five things that embody our
whole existence it's like our Sensations
what we feel our emotions our
perceptions our thoughts and our actions
that's pretty much it and of all of
those the emotions are the most
mysterious it's like it's kind of a
combination of perception and thoughts
you know you can control your behavior
you can control your thoughts people
often forget this but your thoughts are
your choice right I'm not saying you can
suppress thoughts I think there's been a
lot of attention on trying to learn how
to suppress thinking I've never been
able to suppress thinking ever but what
I can do is introduce new thoughts
actually Stephen pressfield who wrote
The War of art
brilliant author and ex-military yeah he
he really I think he said something like
you know he was like in his mid-40s
before he had his first real thought and
what I like to think he was referring to
was the first time that he realized that
you could actually introduce a thought
that thoughts aren't just all
spontaneous so they can be deliberate
you know your Sensations you can control
by your environment and your perceptions
are largely about kind of like what
sends you you know your thoughts about
what you two cents right but your
feelings I think we overvalue feelings
and here I'm going to come across as you
know kind of a hardened male and about
this I you know I would place myself
actually kind of on the wide
emotionality scale but I've learned over
the years that emotions are just kind of
a mishmash of perception and thought I
think we over we overvalue their utility
and this is just my opinion I don't have
any scientific data to support it but I
also don't even know how you study
emotions in the lab every time I see a
laboratory that claims they study
emotions they're studying Behavior every
time there's I you know people are
talking about fear and about courage
they're talking about a behavior that's
measured we don't know what these
animals feel they don't have the
foggiest I don't know what you feel
right now I barely understand what I
feel right now so I think that as a
species we've been and in terms of
mental mental health we've been over
focused on feelings and I think we need
to think more carefully about physiology
both those things breathing and vision
also run in verse meaning if we change
our pattern of breathing we change our
inner state if our state changes our
breathing changes so it's reciprocal
it's bi-directional likewise with vision
when we are excited or stressed the
aperture of our visual window shrinks we
get that soda straw view of the world
when we are relaxed the aperture of our
vision expands but as well it runs in
both directions if we expand our view of
the world literally Force our our visual
field or just it's very easy actually
you can do it no matter where you are
right now if you just try and expand
your visual field not by looking around
or moving your head or eyes but by
trying to see yourself in the
environment that you're in so you
literally dilate your views you could
see the ceiling and the floor and the
walls if you're inside or if you're
Outdoors seeing as big an aperture of
your visual field or your visual
environment as possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal State towards stress
this is why when you go to a a Vista or
you view a horizon it's very relaxing
because you naturally go into panoramic
vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at computer or
a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal State
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or Obsession or Fascination but the
important thing to realize is that both
vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal State of Mind and Body and
it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says tries
changes in our breathing and our vision
but our breathing and our vision can
also Drive changes in our internal State
and so that article in Scientific
American was a discussion about how we
can leverage the visual system and the
respiration the breathing system in
order to take control over our internal
State because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal State determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel like we're having a hard time
falling asleep or we're having a hard
time focusing for instance it also
determines how we batch time how we
analyze where we are in the world in
terms of our lifespan a good example
this would be when we are very stressed
we find sliced time this is why when
people are in a car accident or
something they might report that things
were in slow motion they're actually
your frame rate increases whereas when
you're very relaxed your frame rate
slows down and when we are relaxed we
get so-called perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or I can place this stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to how our nervous system
works is that we are constantly placing
our experience both our immediate and
past experience as well as our
anticipation of the future into some
sort of larger context and our visual
system literally how we are viewing the
world at that moment dictates how we
create perspective in terms of states of
Mind sounds a little bit abstract but
it's actually it boils right down to
Optics of the eye and very concrete
things like how you move your eyes and
how you view the world a growth mindset
which is the academic Discovery and
laboratory discovery of my colleague
Carol dwack at Stanford is the Hallmark
of growth mindset is really two things
one is I'm not where I want to be now
but I but I will I'm capable of getting
there eventually the other is to attach
a sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the result
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true hyper performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peek and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of ups
and downs but really people who are on
that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine to the
effort process and actually Carol's one
of her original studies on the discovery
of growth mindset was these kids that
love doing math problems that they knew
they couldn't get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so incidentally
these kids are fantastic at math when
there is a right answer because they
they feel some sense of reward from the
effort process yeah now the cool thing
about dopamine
is that it's very subjectively
controlled we can all learn to secrete
dopamine in our brain in response to
things that are in a purely subjective
way our interpretation our
interpretation and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on the fact
that the effort process is allowing them
to climb out of their hole potentially
that it's giving them an opportunity
that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or if they're
not in movement along that path or at
least oriented on the right path they're
not lying in bed all day they're taking
a step if they can reward that process
internally two things happen
first of all the brain circuits that are
associated with building subjective
rewards and dopamine gets stronger so
you get better at that process and
second and most importantly dopamine has
an amazing ability to buffer adrenaline
and buffer epinephrine and what I mean
by that is there was a study that was
published in the journal cell excellent
Journal cell Press Journal a couple
years ago showing that with repeated
bouts of effort we use and we release
more and more epinephrine it's kind of
adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you may
look for this let's keep it if I were to
keep it in the business context every
time you make to write that email every
time you let's say it's a person who's a
Craftsman and a crafts woman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're taking a little bit of money out
of this epinephrine account you're
spending epinephrine at some point
those levels of epinephrine get high
enough that you you feel like quitting
it feels exhaustive and this was done in
a beautiful study actually where
um they control the visual environments
and they have the subjects EX exert
effort and they can control the visual
environment so sometimes the effort of
of taking steps and moving forward is
actually kind of pushing forward and
kind of swimming motion
um would give them the Sensation that
they were actually making progress and
other times it was an exercise in
futility where they would just keep the
the visual World stationary and they
would expend effort and they didn't
think they were going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually they quit now dopamine is
able to push back on that epinephrine
and give you
anyone the the feeling that you could
continue and maybe even the feeling that
you want to continue and you've seen
this actually like football is a good
example two teams play say the Super
Bowl both teams are Max effort the
entire time yeah Max effort
the team that wins suddenly in a moment
has the energy to jump all over the
place party for days they can talk I
mean
right before that well that wasn't
glycogen or stored energy of any kind
except it was neural energy and what
happened was effort is this adrenaline
adrenaline adrenaline adrenaline
eventually people quit they just quit
the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it I'm never gonna
argue that we can subjectively control
all of our experience because there's
some things that just genuinely suck
right and when they and it's important
and it's important to register those
those not so great events or terrible
events because they can drive us also
you know we can be driven from a place
of anger frustration and and you know
revenge or we can be driven from a place
of you know love gratitude and Etc I'm
not here to judge which one is better or
worse but the nervous system doesn't
distinguish between them so if you're
the kind of person that needs to you
know kind of budge yourself into
something great if you're the kind of
person that wants to do things from more
of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine too
what I will say is this the ability to
tap into this dopamine reward system
which is activated anytime you're in
pursuit of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know touch and comfort
and things like that with loved ones the
ability to tap into both is crucial now
you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do I don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in but when people start to
realize that thoughts are very much like
physical actions of reaching and picking
up a glass of water or taking a jog
around the ball block or typing an email
perfectly this is something I sometimes
do because I'm I you know I struggle to
do the perfect email not all my emails
are perfect but when I do one I make
sure that I I complete and I think okay
it's possible it's not because the email
being perfect is so important it's
because I want to remind myself that my
thoughts and my actions are essentially
the same the nervous system can organize
thoughts so for somebody that's
struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we we
have so many examples like that but in
trying to make it actionable it's really
about saying yep that's all true but I'm
going to introduce a thought which is I
made it through today I'm I made it
through today and that's actually worth
celebrating at a micro level so if you
can give yourself dopamine rewards in
small increments right you're not trying
to celebrate that you made it through
one day sometimes that's a huge feat but
most of the time you just want to dose
yourself with a little bit of that
internal release of dopamine you start
rewarding incremental steps and if
there's anything that your listeners
could take away from this whole thing
about dopamine and reward schedules and
being in movement it's reward
incremental steps in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards Etc so to make it actionable I
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
I can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way I can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh I'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently I don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push
[Music]
the video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Joe dispenza check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the victim is saying I'm feeling
this way because that person that
circumstance or I don't have any money
is causing me to feel this way that's my
relationship with money what that really
means is I'm using my lack to reaffirm